[Music]
it's been putting the big three are the
three in the big three for the first two
years and now it's just it's putting the
big along with the three in the third
year it just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and big three is
coming back at you later on in June June
twenty seconds is just mentioned to one
of our callers Jeff in Detroit it opens
up in Detroit in 11 weeks season four
more teams more new players Lisa Leslie
is coaching it is just all kinds of
awesome and the founder and co-ceo of
big three professional basketball Ice
Cube good to see you sir hey how you
doing I am great I mean this is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger the name it
looked out at me out of all of them just
Joe Johnson oh yeah I saw Joe now
because he what was the number
Chris 12th on the on the three points
live off all-time and NBA is pretty
awesome he's he is a one of the most
underrated players of the last 20 years
yeah no quiet assassin you know he's not
a you know big rah-rah guy so sometimes
the the guys that are not rah-rah you
know don't you know end up in the
foreground so but his game speaks for
itself
we was ecstatic to get him because you
know we want names to get fans excited
sure you know and guys that still can
play you know because it's not about
your name it's about your game I always
say that but when you got a guy with a
name that still got game
it just helps the league I mean when you
said I Sojo half court is perfect for
him yes it's absolutely the perfect fit
for your league and he's a name that
people can absolutely leap to Lamar Odom
is another one that low off the page
yeah now how much do you personally have
in arm-twisting or saying best role in
the college about decisions you know
these college dudes that go sit in the
living rooms with you know slide momma a
few dollars you know I mean that's easy
you know I mean trying to get these guys
who've been all-stars in the NBA
champions first-round picks first
overall picks you know getting them to
sign on it
you know you know we're proud of that
Kenyon Martin was the first guy to ever
sign with the league and so that was a
big accomplishment I remember me and
Jeff like flipping out like yeah we got
a guy signed to the league and we knew
you know once you get one guy and he
starts talking you get another guy he
starts talking you get another guy and
so you know guys must love the league
cuz they're you know they're talking to
each other and they wouldn't be joining
if they didn't love it well I mean I was
mentioning earlier as well you got well
over a hundred guys to at your combine
yes for only a third of the spots yeah
so there's competition here now without
a doubt also which is what you need you
and you need name recognition unity buzz
you need a cool factor and you obviously
need a network sponsor or partner and
you got one of this DBS yes um so I'm
wondering if do you feel like you've
turned a corner here in year 3 we still
feel like you know we got a hump to get
over you know it's still you know people
out there that don't know about the big
three sponsors are still like you know
dipping their toe in you know I mean so
you know we know we still got more work
to do and we can't you know just be
satisfied we got to keep pushing and we
feel like this is a hump year we feel
like if we if we do a good ratings
number with CBS that they'll they'll you
know bless us with a multi-year deal and
you know and we can you know really grow
to sleep well I mean cuz as you know
you've you've seen a league in spring
football the aaf couldn't even didn't
even complete its first season a man is
hard I know so what what is the biggest
challenge for you know during your three
cube you know the biggest challenge is
just you know we're going to two nights
a week we got more teams so that's more
you know we got two arenas to fill up a
week instead of one so there's a lot of
work to do
but we feel like we have the product and
we have the atmosphere you know it's
very you know I guess you know you it's
very
cost-effective you know how we do things
we have a very affordable price for the
family to come out to a game a lot of
other major sports leagues have kind of
priced
people out of good seats and so you know
we're doing things that we need to do to
keep growing but no one's resting no
one's you know satisfied we feel like
you know let's let's get busy we're
ready to ready to get to work
IceCube here on the Rich Eisen show
there and again the reason why I don't
know I can't get off of the name Joe
Johnson is that what would make this
league also ingrained is to have an NBA
player who is like Joe Johnson yes
12th on the all-time three-point list go
through an accomplished NBA career
yes I love the game I want to keep
playing I'm gonna play it for cubes
League and and to have that sort of
pipeline already set up yeah I mean we
do the same thing with with Jason Terry
right now he just stepped off the NBA
court and that's the you know that's the
whole idea we want guys that still want
to play they want don't want to play 82
games they don't want to play
back-to-backs
they don't want to chase you know John
Wall up and down the court but they do
want to show their skills in the half
court setting there's no joke you know
you still got to know how to play and
you got to be a two-way player and you
got to have you know all-around game to
play two three on three games so you
know you can come in this league and
show different kind of skills you know
by us dropping their age 27 we feel like
some guys are gonna maybe go back into
the NBA you know they didn't get it they
get the rice shot or they didn't get the
right look and you know in our league
they can play in the summer show Scouts
what they got and maybe they'll give
invited back to a camp because guys at
27 are still in a prime and you know
this is this is what the league is all
about this is what we've grown to it and
I know people that that you know our
visionaries can really see where this
thing can go and then there's Greg Oden
now you're given someone another
opportunity if someone named that yeah
there's associate I mean look Ryan Leaf
is sat in on this show he's been its
guest host a couple of times
and he talks about how difficult it is
to live with the word bust or what it
was for him to live with the word bust
now what was it like recruiting Odin to
get him to try and get out there I mean
we're excited for guys who still got the
passion you know so which he does yes
and you know he he tried to he join the
draft who last year and he just didn't
get drafted and this year I think he you
know made it an effort to show people
what he what he still got and and Andre
Owens picked him up and hydrated called
me weeks and said I'm gonna get Greg
nobody take him imma get him and so you
know he did his thing and now he get a
chance to show the world that he's not a
bus that he still can play you know we
had Kwame Brown a couple of you know
years and and here I went through the
same kind of you know I guess jacket you
know and he was able to come in and show
that he still got game he still can play
and he's not a bus
well I follow you on twitter at Ice Cube
and I also follow the league chairman
Amy Trask but yeah we do know I would do
no less and I noticed that when the
conversation in the NBA has been over
the last couple weeks about Becky Harmon
make may be getting a shot of being a
head coach and a woman being a head
coach of a team in the NBA mm-hmm
everyone you Amy tweeting out well look
at the big three our coach last year is
a champion and yes and Nancy Lieberman
who I love and Lisa Leslie now as well
why do you think that works for you in
the big three and it could on how it
could work in the NBA cube I mean well
you know it works it shows our our our
attitude as a lead you know diversity is
paramount in our league and given you
know given you know uh you know Nancy a
shot and we knew what Amy could do given
Lisa a shot this year
to us is is just like smart I mean not
only do they have the cachet and our
Hall of Fame - yeah some of
you know best you know players they ever
touch the ball but you know they have
the passion and you know to me it's
really all about you know wanting to do
the job and taking this serious and
Nancy you know show what she's all about
last year and that's why she won the
championship and I expect Lisa to come
in and do well
Cuttino Mobley put it best he said you
know women taught us how to walk and
speak they can damn show show us how to
dribble and shoot so you know it's it's
a no-brainer to us it's bit you know
it's not a hard decision to make it's
very easy few more minutes left here
with ice cube on the Rich Eisen show all
right let's talk about the NBA right now
yeah you think the Warriors going to
take it all regardless of what we're
seeing the Conference Finals right yep I
do
I think you know they've been there and
they know what it takes
they've had a little you know I guess
adversity you know during the season and
now and I think the guys on the floor
have something to prove you know even
though they've won championships in
Mississippi they you know third I mean
it was third and fourth in five years
that they still want to prove you know
if they have to do it without Katie that
you know they're able to step up to that
challenge
and a team that's that deep with
something to prove who's dangerous you
think Katie's out the door a lot of
people think he's already made his
decision everybody on his team says he's
not I think it would be nuts to assume
that he's gonna leave right now - you
know it's like he's he's gonna be a
three-time champion right yeah you know
and he has nothing to prove to me you
know so he won't even would be you know
him to me just showing he still feel
like he has something to prove but to me
you know he's still wanted the best you
know - three players in the world ever I
don't know ever was like Kevin Durant I
mean if he but what I'm saying is if he
stays there
keeps winning and he's got five six
rings by the end of his warriors staying
you wouldn't be able to sit there and
see he's one of the greatest of all time
like of course I'm gonna say he's one of
the greatest of all times you know but
I'm always say one of the greatest you
know I don't think you can measure all
times and in terms of what we're seeing
in the Eastern Conference Finals we
could go talk about Yanis and and we
could also talk about Kauai but so many
people talk about Drake putting his
hands on a nurse what you figure that
cube him putting on he's having a good
time you know me I don't I I wouldn't
you know stepped over that line and make
myself part of the game in any kind of
way other than just being a fan maybe
yelling at a reference to but you know
you know he's the king of Canada he's
feeling it not just his Raptors but the
shoulders of the head coach yeah like I
said Drake is the king of cannabis and
before I let you go I would be remiss if
I didn't hit you in a couple more topic
so that's cube here your Raiders have
totally reimagined themselves it looks
like right now my guy from the NFL
Network Mike Mac is the gentle man yeah
he's made all sorts of moves from
getting Antonio Brown to drafting guys
who fit a certain mold of go-getters
great guys on and off the field it looks
like this year's gonna be better would
you agree with that cube I'm gonna take
a wait-and-see approach you know you got
to give a man more than one year to
rebuild the team so you know he's the
coach we're gonna I'm gonna give him the
time to rebuild the team you know I
think you know I'll be happy with I
would love a 10-8 this year yes I would
love eight and eight or better you know
I'm saying but you know I give you gotta
give him more than one year to really
turn this thing all the way what do you
think of Brown what do you think of baby
nothing love is added to you know he
always shows up to play and and writers
you gotta gotta have somebody shaking it
up in there
can't have like a standard Raider team
with no personality of flavor last one
subject for you here cube the passing of
John Singleton I'd love to give you the
the floor on what he meant to you
obviously you in boys in the hood that
was your first role if I'm not me
so what what what are your thoughts on
on the untimely passing of John
Singleton well you know first of all I
love that man you know Jeff singleton is
it was everything to me you know a
friend a mentor confidant cheerleader
you know Big Brother you know in in
definitely in the industry and you know
just think of all the people
John put into show business and put in a
good light and the things they went on
to do like I wouldn't be sitting here
without John Singleton my path to get
here would would have been totally you
know thrown off off the path so why is
that why is that what he well got a
story of something specific well he he
discovered me in the movie industry and
he not only turned me into a movie star
but he turned me into a filmmaker you
know he helped me become a writer
he helped me become a director he came
in when I did my first movie players
club
when I first directed I was so
overwhelmed at one point that John
jumped in and helped me block a scene
and and coordinated and get it where it
can be shot correctly you know things
like that he would uh he would just you
know make sure that you know he was he's
my Scorsese you know Robert De Niro they
you know they got a thing with essence a
Z John is my guy you know and Spike has
his guys but so we all feel like that
you know me Cuba Gooding jr. taraji
Regina King Regina King
mr. Reese she just won an Oscar yeah you
know Tyrese so we all feel that way
about this man and without him you know
I'm not putting on Chris Tucker I'm not
putting on my caps I don't have a
vehicle to put on Terry Crews Katt
Williams you know the list goes on and
on other people that I was able to help
just because John Singleton came and got
me
did true he told you right Friday he
said what he told me to write a movie
okay um that I was sitting with me one
day in this house and you said man when
you're gonna write a movie I'm like John
I'm I'm trying to be you know do good
and boys in the hood it's like not only
here that you say you can write a record
like the records you write I know you
can write a movie that day I went
brought a computer I bought a program
and I started to try to write a movie
and then I wasn't got his help and um
and he helped me become a writer who
could write a movie like Friday which is
my third script you know not my first
and then I guess by extension that no
big three well big three a lot of knows
no Friday no barbershop no you know good
list goes on yeah I mean I was it really
hit me when I heard that age 51 51 years
old way too young are you where who's
that are not my next guest in our number
three uh yeah I think it's uh junior
chip off the old queue coming in here in
a big movie now Godzilla's not as big is
as a get so we so proud of him and he's
such a good dude and you know you gonna
have fun with him yeah I know I know I
think he is he here already
is he here already okay would you mind
if we brought him out for just a quick
second what's not okay I just father and
son all right all right let's take a
break and maybe we come back and stick
the two of you guys here together for
just a quick minute do it for maybe and
then and then O'Shea will just spend as
much time as we want on our number three
and by the way both of you have been on
my wife's podcast the official Lakers
podcast it's a family affair it is a
fast month
the aizen's and the cubes if you will
when we come back here on the rich eyes
and show the big three get tickets right
now big three.com slash tickets right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app